[Música]
hola qué tal lo que viene encontrarnos
nuevamente como lo hacemos regularmente
todos los viernes acá para esta reunión
semanal de canadá en las américas café
de este viernes 13 de septiembre en vivo
y en directo por nuestro sitio internet
por facebook live youtube y también por
donde más
por nuestros intentos en nuestro sitio
estamos todos con este eje la aplicación
la aplicación a la falta de la
aplicación vamos a hablar ahorita más
tarde bueno ya se dieron cuenta
leonora chapman leonard a menos mil
personas les presentamos este programa
de este viernes 13 que por algunos lares
viernes 13 es de mal agüero pero aquí no
sobre todo aquí pero en latinoamérica
estábamos conversando fuera de micrófono
ahorita y bueno por lo menos en
argentina y de colombiano es el viernes
3 es el martes 13
en realidad creo que nació con la
historia de la película viernes 13
una película de terror
clases traducidas al américa latina o
américa central no se encienden en el
martes llegó martes entonces fue dama un
martes 13 o por lo menos se le tradujo
así porque era el día de la mala suerte
ah bueno bueno pese a antes que se
envolvió de un caluroso saludo hallar
todos los que nos están escuchando del
otro lado del micrófono y de las cámaras
un placer tenerlos con nosotros aquí en
esta reunión familiar casi de todos los
viernes
bueno les recordamos ya que estamos
hablando de reunión familiar que los
invitamos a que nos envíen fotos y
vídeos que ustedes tengan de de su
pueblo de su ciudad de su calle de lo
que quieran y nosotros lo pasamos acá -
vídeos porno porque si ya se concedan ya
la costa y ya no podemos
[Música]
de trabajo nos ayudan pero a perder el
trabajo y esa no es la idea así que
bueno no lo su calle fotos en fin lo que
pueda nosotros lo pasamos aquí en
nuestro programa canadá en las américas
café y bueno hablando de fotos
justamente hablando de fotos
yo creo que
vamos a hablar de los kiwis hoy en día y
no sé si pierre me está escuchando los
kiwis yo por lo menos los kiwis que
conocía eran la fruta ahí está la fruta
y este pajarito que está ahí bueno
pajarito no a como pájaro es de como una
gallina bien gordita
se sabe que se llama kiwi también en
australia
y entonces para todo esto para decirle a
césar que está ahí del otro lado que los
kiwis que yo conocía son este y wii la
fruta y que me decía césar fuera de
micrófono que es una fruta que es muy
popular allá en bogotá donde se
encuentra en este momento y bueno está
esta ave que se llama kiwi también de
australia nueva zelandia o algo así yo
no sé qué hacen con eso pero si
estuviera en colombia en barranquilla
hacían un sancocho
[Risas]
muchas ganas que estaba ahí por lo menos
y bueno todo esto para presentarles a
nuestro invitado de hoy que estás
acompañándonos desde bogotá colombia por
skype así que él se trata de césar
augusto rodríguez harris echarri digo él
es un antiguo digo antiguo o viejo
oyente de radio canadá porque nos
escuchaba desde hace mucho tiempo desde
la onda corta es un amigo de lo que era
contestación a la correspondencia que se
convirtió en el castor mensajero que
después se dedicó lloret camps en canadá
en las américas café entonces césar está
con nosotros justamente para conversar
sobre kiwis pero el kiwi que él nos va a
presentar es un kiwi muy particular es
ese de er radio que es un aparatito que
permite captar las ondas y bueno de eso
vamos a hablar justamente con él
bienvenido césar
muy buenos días y muchas gracias por
invitarme al espacio de ustedes es
semanal
bueno pues un gran placer tenerte con
nosotros al menos ahí compartiendo tu
allá en bogotá y nosotros aquí en
montreal a la tecnología
[Aplausos]
ya pasamos estamos justamente hablando
de onda corta y hablando de ondas de
radio
césar explícanos por favor que comen en
invierno estos kiwi a este kiwi que tú
nos vas a presentar deje que parece que
hubiese de esradio
bueno estos kiwis en todas las épocas
del año lo que comen son
condiciones de radio así emisiones de
radio
en toda la época del año entonces lo que
hace de estos aparaticos es recibir las
ondas de radio y convertirlas en una
señal digital que se envía directamente
por internet y bueno lo que pasa es que
cualquier persona que se pueda conectar
a internet puede manejar este aparatito
desde su casa como si estuviera
sintonizando un radio que estuviera por
ejemplo acá en bogotá pero de tonto
tienes más preguntas entonces vamos con
eso si lo que sobra a leonard de la
pregunta es esto es un aparatito que uno
pone
conectado a la computadora y a partir de
un software podemos leer
escuchar más en realidad escuchar y leer
en el sentido de que la muela plano que
la computadora está leyendo
informaciones o interpreta voy a
escuchar radio a md cualquier parte del
mundo si correcto el aparatico es esta
que está acá que saber cuál es por un
lado entra la onda de radio es decir
esto está conectado a una antena
exterior y si análoga en red y wii y
destacable está conectado directamente a
internet no necesita otro computador
este es el computador si tiene raps
barry pi registra raspberry y otras
tarjetas
y entonces va conectado directamente al
computador y una persona que esté
conectada a internet puede sintonizar la
el rango de frecuencia que se encuentra
por ejemplo en bogotá y desplazarse por
todo el m y la onda corta y uso de
manejes las de raps berries y la raíz
barry en realidad son unas
microcomputadoras que en realidad uno
dependiendo de la cantidad de puertos de
la cantidad de salidas que tenga y
entradas es un aparato de este tamaño
aproximadamente y eso funciona como una
computadora una computadora no la
nuestra que tenemos el trabajo eso
conectado a un disco rígido conectado a
el mouse conectado al teclado conectado
al entrar a la pantalla es una
computadora eso así pero él me dice que
tiene la raps barry que es la
computadora como tal tamaño del teléfono
y una plaqueta para poder entrar la
información
análoga y convertirla en digital digital
eleonora si yo tengo una pregunta si
entiendo bien entonces la cosa uno se
convierte en receptor teniendo ese
aparato puedes acceder a contenidos de
radios de todo el mundo finalmente es
que uno puede convertirse también en
emisor
pues este está para tico lo que está
haciendo es emitir las ondas de radio
análogas que se escuchan a cam bogotá
eso lo puede hacer y una idea que yo
tengo es que todas las personas que
tengan este aparato en su casa puedan
construir un aparato emisor de am desde
su propia casa y entonces el mismo
raspberry que se tiene en su casa lo
recibe y entonces la emisión se escucha
al lado de otras emisoras de onda corta
como si fuera una emisora de onda corta
más pero en realidad es un pequeño
transmisor que el mismo raspberry el
mismo que we está recibiendo a una muy
corta distancia entonces si uno puede
tener un transmisor de un y de un vatio
que no sale del circuito de su casa
puede hacer como si tuviera una emisora
de onda corta
y que aquí cómo manejas eso digamos un
día cualquiera césar ahí estás en tu
casa y prendes ese aparato y qué haces y
le habla al mundo donde está prohibido
el aparato
ahí está aprendido y se necesita un
transmisor pequeño de aemme adicional
que ya estamos haciendo pruebas ya nos
salieron bien las pruebas y sería hacer
una emisión digamos semanal porque pues
también tenemos por lo menos yo otros
trabajos pero se puede hacer una emisión
semanal y sale al lado de otras emisoras
al lado de radio miami internacional han
dado de radio rumanía o de radio habana
cuba como si fuera en realidad es como
cambian sackville por una persona porque
porque me imagino que eso no tiene un
gran coste un costo cualquier persona
puede convertirse entonces en un emisor
de su estación el costo cuánto cuesta
cesar un costo de ochoa y bueno
el kiwi vale 200 dólares
y hay que colocar una antena y otros
pequeños aditamentos como una
alimentación de corriente y hay que
construir un pequeño transmisor de amd
que también podría contar unos 102
dólares eso eso es en el caso de que si
mal no comprendí en el caso de que uno
quiera emitir y hacer como si tuviera
tiene una onda corta ahora al emitir si
es que tenía una pregunta acá para cesar
porque quiero comprender bien tú hablas
césar turnos estás hablando de amplitud
modulada ondas
m puede contar bien procesar la
frecuencia modulada y la onda corta
también pues los que todavía no son
capaces de cubrir el rango de fm
entonces esperamos que pronto quizás más
adelante se desarrolle esa tecnología
por ahora solamente es aemet lo
interesante es que por ejemplo yo puedo
ser solamente emisor con el kiwi sin el
otro transmisor y si uno está por
ejemplo recibiendo yo puedo conectarme a
otros kiwi en el mundo hay un poco más
de 400 no son muchos no son muchos no
son muchos y creo que en canadá hay unos
tal vez alguno de montreal y yo puedo
entrar al de montreal y escuchar las
emisoras locales de montreal o escuchar
cómo se escucha en las emisoras de onda
corta que llegan a montreal
tú tenías una pregunta
estaba pensando ya en términos tal vez
más lejos pero me di cuenta que no hay
todavía mucho no está muy extendida esta
tecnología pero finalmente si encuentras
gente y como vos que tiene el kiwi en tu
casa se podrían formar también unas
redes de kiwi
y ahí viene la cuestión genético un
racimo de kiwis ya the sky is the limit
y qué utilidad digamos puede servir para
que tener un aparato de eso en la casa
en caso de una catástrofe por ejemplo
serviría no sé para avisar a las
autoridades lo que estás usando se me
estoy tratando de imaginar lo que puede
servirnos qué utilidad tiene el que
cumpliría la función que cumplió la onda
corta en aquella época y ti aún todavía
va mano de alguna manera cumple esa
función de onda corta pero por ejemplo
para los y exista si los
radioaficionados es antes de santé
porque por ejemplo un radioaficionado
que está en francia y quiere saber si su
señal está llegando a colombia el emite
de francia y se sintoniza micr y wii y
se da cuenta cómo está llegando su señal
hasta esta región por ejemplo entonces
pues esto es como un servicio más que
todo yo lo veo así ya no sé el lyon alto
si hay algún comentario no no se había
lephone o sientes y te comentarios hay
saludos acá voy a leerlos esta esmeralda
villegas uribe dice estoy viendo al
amigo césar charry radista de vieja data
especialmente de onda corta
felicitaciones césar luís valdez a dice
en la zona de tal que en el centro de su
de chile se producen kiwis una fruta y
muy buena calidad
en este caso habla de la fruta luís
baldera dice saludos a mi amigo ignacio
rojas que siempre trae kiwis de talca
dice danilo nonato dice grandes amigos
desarrollo es charly saludos desde
brasil y alessandro ignacio
eso dice que no sé qué significará esos
son los mensajes que tenemos hasta el
momento bueno las palabras no caen al
vacío césar sigue con nosotros por
supuesto que la pregunta mía es hay
alguna interface web donde yo puede
entrar para poder ir a ver los 'kiwis'
que están conectados y de paso debemos
saber dónde hay demasiado pues no se
sabe dónde está vos hablaste de unos 500
400 kiwis sabes eso bueno que se puede
entrar a la página
ese de rr.ee
aunque repuntó archivo allí hay un mapa
y se puede mirar en el mapa donde están
lo escribí o del buscador se coloca el
país o la ciudad y allí te aparece lo
que hay conectado césar porque hay tan
pocos kiwis en el mundo a qué se debe
siendo que es una tecnología más o menos
accesible no al mundo a la gente sí pues
no sé yo creo que es tal vez información
la cuestión económica porque en américa
latina hay unos 11 tal vez solamente en
colombia solamente hay este pero en
europa y en eeuu hay muchos
entonces puede ser información o
situación económica tal vez se necesita
una antena
exterior bueno yo creo que leonardo ya
tiene ya está conectado a esa que se
entre a ese punto h
se puede ver
desde el celular se puede en la pantalla
también está yo lo estoy viendo desde
aquí tiene un montón de radios no sé si
estáis ahí se ve ahí se ve un poquito
mejor no hice la lista de radio que pone
en vertical para que se vea la lista de
radios que están conectadas y aquí en
italia suiza grecia
[Música]
no sudeste de el reino unido ucrania
suiza grecia españa australia es
increíble un montón de mundo de la rabia
que pueden entrar y está realmente muy
completo es un proyecto súper
interesante
voy a ir a chismosos era un poco y él me
pregunte pregunta a césar cómo fue que
te interesaste en esta tecnología qué
fue lo que te decidió decir yo la quiero
tenerla adoptaste pues pues se me
ocurrió que se podría hacer una emisión
también desde su cárcel de la casa
porque yo sabía que existía y un día se
me ocurrió llame a un amigo y le dije
oiga será que podemos hacer esto y me
dijo pues intentémoslo y pues se puede
hacer esa es una idea mía nadie de estos
kiwis que están acá que yo sepa tienen
planeado transmitir desde su propia casa
para crear una propia emisora y
colocarla sobre el espectro combinando
lo análogo y lo digital
entonces pues es una idea yo invito a
todos los que puedan tener un kiwi a que
lo hagan y como soy muy malicioso césar
entonces creo leer en tu mente ahí
detrás de recrear nuevamente radio
ciudad global
pues de alguna manera vamos a ver si sea
la misma radio ciudad global o una
fiduciaria o algo derivado de la misma
reducida global podríamos saber que es
un adiós ciudad global explica el
entonces bueno radio ciudad global fue
una un proyecto de una emisora
internacional vía internet dado que en
colombia nunca ha habido una emisora de
onda corta o internacional entonces yo
dije voy a hacerla en internet y
estuvimos transmitiendo unos cuatro años
en esto me acompañó mucho omar alfredo
ortiz
los derechos y omar y toda la parte
digamos tecnológica él me ayudó mucho y
también hacíamos varios programas y pues
nos fue muy bien teníamos muchos oyentes
casi 4.000
en casi 120 o 130 países del mundo pero
hablaste el pasado porque qué pasó con
ese radio pues se cerró por diferentes
cuestiones yo quería llevarla a un
estado superior
y profesionalizarla más y pues por
tiempo y porque no había muchos recursos
pues no se pudo hacer entonces cerrarla
en ese momento como dicen colombia
cuando faltan ganas
bueno yo no sé si tienen algunas
preguntas más para césar o yo me voy a
poner a chusmear un poco de qué se trata
de esto y después hablaremos con ser
pues ya tendremos la oportunidad de
regresar sobre el tema contigo o césar
muchísimas gracias muy amable por
haberte prestado para este juego acá de
canadá en las américas café y para dar a
conocer este tercer kiwi que yo no
conocía independientemente de eso yo los
invito porque césar tiene una página es
fotógrafo también tiene una página de
fotografía el otro día estuve tomando
sus fotos son precios realmente muy
bonitas
aquí no se escapa nada acá estamos
investigado lo que se puede
bueno muchísimas gracias ser amable de
tu parte y buena suerte con este
proyecto y espero que se puede expandir
y que crezca bueno muchas gracias y
saludos a todos ya los oyentes también
gracias a dios césar que a ritmos
rodríguez charlie nos acompañaba desde
bogotá colombia para presentarnos a esta
nueva tecnología que
bueno pues puede ser útil para todo
aquel que tenga sobre todo el que tiene
la pasión por la radio fisio enviamos
por la radioafición radioaficionado es
una persona que le encanta estas cosas
porque la utilidad como tal si la radio
el radioaficionado tenía la onda corta y
escuchaba noticias de otros lugares
ahora esos digamos como que ha quedado
relegado por la velocidad el internet al
podio uno accede a ese tipo de cosas en
un solo clic en una computadora pero hay
gente que le gusta el tema de la
transmisión de radio y este tipo de
cosas hacen que eso digamos sigue
estando no es cierto el amor por la
radio y el amor por este tipo de cosas
implica
yo creo que llega sobre todo el corazón
del radio de aficionados y de la gente
que les gusta la radio como nosotros yo
lo que les veo un gran gran gran
potencial yo digo es la producción la
emisión de contenidos pensemos solamente
en estas famosas radios piratas que
nosotros una persona que tiene sabe cómo
manejar en la web en internet puede
tener su propia radio imagínate esto
un bank costo tan barato y que en un
momento dado pues yo creo que puede ser
algo extraordinario cada persona se
convierte en un en un emisor de alguna
noticia que quiere dar al mundo en fin
hay mucho potencial en este fantástico y
sobre todo para la gente que le gusta la
radio a mí me llama la atención pues yo
soy un como decíamos en argentina un
[ __ ] de radio así que me llamó mucho la
atención
de radio entonces además de servicio de
radio leo
recuerdo que son las 1336 no me apure no
me puede si usted me pide las efemérides
de las efemérides el 8 de septiembre
vamos la de la semana por supuesto no
las más importantes de la semana el 8 de
septiembre fue el día internacional de
la alfabetización es también el día
internacional del periodista saluda a
todos los periodistas a todos aquellos
que cumplen la función también aunque no
sean periodistas de escuela el 10 de
septiembre el día mundial para
la prevención del suicidio y estos son
datos concretos y son escalofriantes
solo en las américas hay siete suicidios
por hora
las franjas más golpeadas son los
adolescentes el 11 de septiembre fue en
argentina particularmente el día del
maestro así que les mandamos a los
maestros a todos ellos un abrazo grande
el 13 de septiembre el día del
programador es otro y un día muy
especial que es el día de internacional
del chocolate así que para festejar el
día internacional de chocolate le saque
la marca le saque la marca para no hacer
publicidad pero de qué se trata el mejor
así que allí compartimos el chocolate y
ahí le vamos a pedir a la gente de aquel
lado ahí vamos a cambiarle el chocolate
a la gente que está haciendo señales
en su parte mientras que leonardo se
desconecta leonora tu dentro de lo
insólito tu nos hablas de un animal un
volador enorme que descubrieron en el
aquí en canadá creo que pues es
chocolate estamos hablando de un animal
de que existió hace 70 millones de años
siempre me pregunto como hacen los
científicos para determinar que un [ __ ]
existió hace 70 millones de años pero
vamos a creerle a los científicos
carbono-14
este [ __ ] existió hace 77 millones de
años se llama crío dragón bóreas es uno
de los animales ahí lo podemos ver en la
pantalla volador es el gigantesco en
haber existido podía medir pablo hasta
10 metros de largo sí y fue descubierto
en la provincia de alberta aquí en
canadá donde justamente
hay petróleo hay dinosaurios todo eso
está en alberta y es fue de los restos
fueron encontrados hace 30 años en
alberta pero recién acaba de
identificarse más detalladamente de
quién se trata y esta es una
investigación de la universidad queen
mary de londres en la provincia de
ontario y bueno dice el que dirigió esta
investigación que es de vídeo home dijo
que este descubrimiento nos da una mejor
idea de la diversidad de los
pero saurios pterosaurios en américa del
norte y de su evolución impresionante el
[ __ ] si yo no me imaginaba que una cosa
así tan grande o tonalidad volar 10 que
pueda volar que haya pesado como 240
kilos pero que no haya sido carnívoro es
que se comía los bebés dinosaurios por
las dudas no lo reviven no se ponga a
hacer la experiencia del parque jurásico
no pero justamente así con viejo eso es
carnívoro se comía los bebés y unos
saurios que no sé qué grande eran los
bebés no sabrás
grande pero hay ocasiones que es como un
avión de hoy diez metros de largo 240
kilos en fin no me acuerdo los kilos más
o menos era impresionante y volaba por
la baixa es lo que me mandaste o lo hace
diferente yo quiero resaltar algo que no
es muy simpático de hecho que me
encuentro bastante triste que esto pueda
suceder y fue bueno la real policía
montada de canadá investiga en ese caso
en este momento porque esto sucedió en
el gran vancouver en burnaby en un
bosquecillo un bosque ahí de columbia
británica cuando un muchacho que se
llama jeff cord estaba paseando sus
perros él tiene dos perros huskies
entonces uno de sus perros le trajo
lo agarro un pedazo de carne y lo trajo
para mostrárselo a su amo y ese pedazo
de carne tenía plantadas agujas por
todos lados entonces me parece
absolutamente criminal ahí vemos esa el
pedazo de carne y ven las agujas que que
tenía el pedazo de carne pero hay que
ser malvado como como es posible de que
alguien pueda pensar en hacer eso
afortunadamente para parajes kurt y sus
perros su perro no se abalanzó sobre el
pedazo de carne sino que se lo tragó y
se lo mostró y él le sacó lafuente sacó
la foto y fue el que hizo la denuncia
entonces pues me parece muy triste que
alguien pase que pierda su tiempo en
poner sobre todo en una zona boscosa
pero cualquiera que esté jugando en el
bosque ese época de andar en el bosque
así es entonces pues ese es lo que me
parecía en solitario y eso pueda ocurrir
cuando dijiste triste una noticia pensé
inmediatamente en esa noticia que
hiciste ayer de este señor
en el este canadiense que fue condenado
a 20 años yo era inocente en halifax y
él pasó 20 años en la cárcel y acusado
del asesinato de su esposa cara me
acaban de demostrar que es inocente
entonces 17 años de adn probablemente
que antes no se hacían esos salarios no
existían ahora está todo mucho más
finamente calculado los análisis
entonces pero 20 años de tu vida
terrible y bueno como el tiempo no nos
acosa y leonardo una a una rápida
intervención sobre la aplicación hay
gente que se ha descargado si se siguen
las descargas pero los impulsamos y los
invitamos con con gaitán y furia aparece
en la esquina
y con tanta furia
los invitamos a que descarguen nuestra
aplicación donde tienen la posibilidad
de tener
realmente
en la yema de sus dedos toda la
información de lo que pasa en canadá en
la región y en el mundo gracias a radio
canal internacional ahí están viendo el
vídeo de la aplicación porque la pueden
bajar en cualquiera de las cinco lenguas
en las cuales produce contenidos radio
cada internacional nosotros le sugerimos
que la bajen en español para para que
entiendan de qué se trata
cantones también así que no hay problema
la historia es que es súper sencilla de
manejar y se puede usar muy muy
fácilmente con digamos es como muy
intuitiva así que para todos aquellos
que tengan
digamos es esa proximidad con las
noticias de radio canadá internacional
los invitamos a que hagan
que bajen esta aplicación tienen que
hacerlo desde nuestro sitio de internet
o bien buscando directamente en las
tiendas radio cara internacional y si no
ir a nuestro sitio entender ahora hemos
bajado la publicidad le hemos puesto
abajo porque arriba está de todo lo
concerniente a las elecciones
canadienses así que la publicidad de la
aplicación está un poquito más abajo
hacen clic ahí y tienen las dos grandes
tiendas apple y android para poder bajar
la aplicación y tenerlas directamente en
sus teléfonos después como decía mi
abuelo el que busca en cuenta así es así
es que vamos a un avión ahora se va a
tener que ausentar en un momento dado
porque tiene una entrevista que ir a
hacer entonces vamos a hablar vamos a
hablar del tema que quiere resaltar tú
esta semana leonora y tú nos habla de
una exposición que se está llevando a
cabo aquí en una decisión y si pierre
puede mostrar porque esta fotografía es
una gran gran exposición que se está
llevando en este momento aquí en
montreal en el museo de bellas artes es
la decimosexta bienal de la imagen
museo de bellas artes y la persona a la
artista que viene a presentar ahí como
está escrito a link a echeverría ella es
una antropóloga artista visual tiene una
gran trayectoria poder uno puede ver su
trabajo fotográfico y ella ese proyecto
que está presentando en montreal lo
llama nicéforo que lo llama así por la
versión femenina del nombre del pionero
francés de la fotografía pablo que vos
conocés un poco más del sector
sí que es un trabajo donde ella
reformula la narrativa de las
fotografías coloniales o lo pone bien en
claro a través de una perspectiva
feminista entonces lo interesante es que
yo le pregunté al inca si el hecho de
ser hombre o mujer tiene forzosamente
una mirada diferente por ser de sexos
diferentes en la representación de lo
femenino en la fotografía y su respuesta
fue muy muy buena dijo yo creo que una
fotógrafa puede tener una mirada
masculina y colonial siendo mujer de un
país colonizado entonces tiene que ver
más dice ella con la perspectiva de la
cual venimos y de la conciencia con la
que hacemos el trabajo es decir no
quiere decir gran cosa en este caso que
sea hombre o mujer en que tome esas
fotografías sino más bien tu historia
ella es como antropóloga además tiene
una historia muy interesante alinka ella
es mexicana británica tiene las dos
nacionalidades trabajó como antropóloga
en uganda y en málaga
también en cuba y otros países y eso es
lo que hace interesante también sus
fotografías se ve eso en países
africanos tiene mucha influencia en ella
y también en lo interesante es que ella
estuvo cuando sudán del sur declaró ella
dice que ese es su trabajo el trabajo
más importante que hizo sudando el sur
cuando declaró su independencia
ella estuvo en ese país y estuvo
fotografiando entonces tiene imágenes
increíbles de ese momento
sudan del sur entonces la exposición se
llama simulacro o simulacro como dice
ella también que es un viaje del artista
a los archivos de un museo de francia
bueno ya presenta ahí en un vídeo de
tres minutos son doscientas imágenes y
ella utiliza diversas técnicas entre
esas la fotografía pero también el
collage y otro tipo de foto artes no
para presentar esa exposición entonces
va hasta el primero de octubre el que
tenga pues un tiempito se puede dar ir
al museo de montreal la exposición está
circular para los que están viviendo
aquí en montreal pero para los que viven
fuera y que nos están escuchando yo creo
que ya debe tener un sitio internet en
el sitio internet y esas fotos hay que
ir a mirarlas a veces vale la pena
entonces en su sitio web simplemente
ponen a link a echeverría iba a aparecer
su sitio tiene muchísimas cosas como
artista y también como antropólogo bueno
y eso lo pueden escuchar y ver y lo
bueno escuchar la entrevista que leonora
hizo con aline acá en rc y net
12 a leonardo tenemos por ahí mensajes
de nuestros oyentes y esmeraldas
villegas uribe de excelente información
gracias al equipo de trabajo del radio
canal internacional y a césar gustavo
lucas dice saludos desde la ciudad de
melo departamento de cerro largo en
uruguay siempre pendientes de las
emisiones de radio granta nacional desde
los tiempos en que estaba susana peña de
pu
12 14 años sí imagínate
tenemos también otro mensaje de gustavo
lucas que dice referente a los kiwis
tengo entendido que se denomina también
así a los neos holandeses a los kiwi el
cuarto kiwi el cuarto kiwi
no son más que son kiwi y hay que
ponerle como el vídeo
sí
[Risas]
bueno fantástico tónico prosódico por
favor y bueno vamos a continuar con
algunos mensajes que tenemos acá
represados yo tengo un mensaje acá que
sería que si el tema es tratamiento de
fertilidad trae su lote de
complicaciones advierte investigación
canadiense erik a catherine mesa
arébalos dice queremos buscar una
respuesta a nuestro inconveniente de
poder tener hijos no somos familia de
abundante dinero honestos y creyentes en
el amor de dios'
pero bueno si entiendo que tienen
problemas para tener niños miguel
barrera nos escribe y dice hola les
saluda miguel desde guatemala espero un
día no muy lejano mi esposa y yo poder
ser parte de esta gran nación tener la
oportunidad de estudiar trabajar y poder
vivir legalmente en canadá esto nos dice
miguel desde guatemala
leonardo jiménez si yo tengo un mensaje
aquí el misterioso síndrome de fatiga
crónica será investigado en canadá maria
jose dice me gusta que se pueda
investigar
enfermeros 5 o 6 años hasta que los 25
me diagnosticaron de frío fibromialgia
síndrome de fatiga crónica sí pero se lo
descubrieron recién a los 20 a los 25
años tengo 57 y mi vida ha sido durísima
en la actualidad prácticamente en cama y
poco más ha ido degenerando y
añadiéndose otras muchas enfermedades
lógicos con poco movilidad con ese tipo
de cosas es complicado a mí no me va a
llegar ningún progreso o cura por la
edad que tengo y lo severo de los
síntomas pero desearía que ninguna niña
enferma se como yo es el mensaje de
maría josé es la primera vez que escucho
que hay una niña que sufre de
fibromialgia de certero y debe ser una
niña
es una niña porque yo pensé siempre que
esa enfermedad atacaba a las personas
llamas y santiago flora sentido dice
hola sufro de fibromialgia desde los 5
años también pensé en que me podrían
ayudar porque se me hace cuesta arriba
tanto dolor y si hay algo alternativo
para el dolor que sea natural
lo que sabemos que es alternativo y para
el dolor y es natural es los aceites de
cannabis no sé si para este tipo de
enfermedades pero para los colores en
general eso funciona bastante bien
habría que consultar con el médico y ver
dónde vives si es legal o no sin mensaje
importe bueno de la con respecto a la
fibromialgia mi hija
sufre de fibromialgia ella tiene 34 años
hoy y bueno comenzó a sufrir desde su
adolescencia prácticamente y lo que la
puede lo que le calma le calma el dolor
es justamente derivados del cannabis
aceite y etcétera que es lo que viene a
calmarle el dolor porque eso lo que es
aspirina tylenol
así que aquí tengo otro saludo en este
caso es en el psoe contra el rincón que
dice saludarle
colombi sr saludos nelson cordial saludo
me imagino que ya barranquilla pues está
preparándose para las fiestas
decembrinas porque sí para los
carnavales comienzan a prepararse en
diciembre entonces para fiestas
decembrinas pero podemos comenzar a
prepararnos desde septiembre y luego me
preparo para ver todo acaba de
desaparecer leonor a leonora como les
había dicho ya de antemano tiene una
entrevista que hacer así que se despide
de todos ustedes y por acá yo tengo una
pregunta un tema es los raptors nuevos
campeones de la nba y primer equipo no
estadounidense en ganar el título josé
monsalve dice buenos días en cada
actividad grandiosa del ser humano no
deja de prevalecer la superstición se
termina todo el esfuerzo creativo de
toda la actividad lograda según él
estaba escrito no sé cuál es la relación
del comentario de jose con la de los
raptors
ahora habrá habido algún tipo de
superstición con respecto al triunfo de
los raptors realmente no no tengo idea
yo aquí tengo un mensaje un comentario
que dice falta mano de obra en plantas
pesqueras del atlántico canadiense y
édgar castillo dice que se debe hacer
para trabajar como temporal extranjero
en ese sector soy de guadalajara jalisco
méxico no tengo experiencia pero no y no
hablo inglés pero me interesa laborar en
canadá y para la gente que tenga
intenciones de venir a trabajar en
canadá lo de siempre el sitio de
internet de inmigración canadá es muy
muy muy completo y tienen toda la
información que se necesita para poder
aplicar en los diversos tipos de
inmigración en inmigración como
residente permanente en inmigración como
refugiado en todos los casos que hay
cuatro o cinco categorías especies
específicas ahí se encuentra la
información pertinente
bien y como ya nos conozco si el tiempo
se nos va muy rápidamente prefiero darle
ya los créditos a nuestros técnicos hoy
en los controles técnicos benoit durand
andrés marc andré sá y pierde til
alienados agua punk a menos no nos vamos
todavía a un san papá pero bueno
y yo leonardo siguiendo encadenando con
los temas de la semana que tú quieres
resaltar el tuyo nos habla del fallo de
un en el tratamiento del cáncer y de la
big data exacto que en realidad el fado
fado como tal no pero hay veces que uno
piensa que un
o velas a las personas que están
enfermas de cáncer entonces intenta
hacer cual tratamiento posible sea
necesario para mejorar la calidad de
vida o tratar de salvarlos de ese
problema y hay ciertos tipos de cáncer
que en realidad lamentablemente no
tienen no tienen mucho pero no muy buen
pronóstico en este caso ibm con el
instituto broad comenzaron una
investigación el año 2016 usando la big
data que se obtiene en realidad la big
data es ellos como los impresionantes de
información que se consiguen gracias a
los algoritmos que investigan más de lo
que el ojo humano puede ver está bien
entonces empezar a investigar sobre
todos los análisis que se habían hecho
las biopsias que se habían hecho en
enfermos de ciertos tipos de cáncer y
encontraron información pertinente e
información que daba cuenta que ciertos
tipos de cáncer desarrollan durante el
tratamiento una resistencia al
tratamiento cosa que no se sabe o que no
se sabía hasta el momento en realidad
dije no so el tratamiento daba resultado
y ahora nada más resultado y la persona
termina exacto termina por
lamentablemente
moriré a causa del ataque de este cáncer
bueno entonces en este caso ibm encontró
con este análisis de big data que hay
una posibilidad de que haya mucha
información cubierta y en este punto se
dieron cuenta de que ese tipo de
tratamientos faltaban porque en realidad
no porque el tratamiento no sea bueno
sino porque el cuerpo generaba una
resistencia o el tumor realidad entonces
empezar a investigar y encontraron que
hay muchísimas muchísimas muchísimas
e información que no se ha estudiado
porque son volúmenes de información
increíble que no se pueden o sea si por
ponemos a un investigador a repasar toda
esa información se pasa la vida haciendo
eso y no bueno por ahí encuentre cosas
que corresponden y que signifiquen un
progreso para la ciencia o para la
medicina pero se perdería muchísimo
tiempo en este caso con los algoritmos
de inteligencia artificial y el big data
parece que ese tipo de cosas van a salir
a la luz mucho más rápido y en este caso
encontraron eso puntualmente y es muy
interesante que es la posibilidad de
saber cuando un elemento no corresponde
para el tumor que están tratando está
bien sea un tratamiento no funciona no
funciona porque el tumor está mutando y
no lo deja funcionar como corresponde
entonces se puede ajustar el tratamiento
para tratar de vencer el tumor y otra de
las cosas que descubrieron a darle una
cierta ventaja exacta al tumor y lo que
descubrieron también es que
con ciertos análisis puntualmente
análisis de sangre se pueden encontrar
ese tipo de datos que no sé que antes no
se encontraban no se veían pero parece
que en vez de tener que hacer biopsias
invasivas y con todo lo que significa
una operación y llegar hasta el tumor y
sacar un pedazo de tejido para
analizarlo parece que gracias a la big
data también encontraron que es posible
todavía no está obviamente
institucionalizado pero que es posible
encontrar este tipo de resistencia y un
montón de información sólo con análisis
sanguíneos bueno muy rápidamente porque
ya se queda poco tiempo
yo quiero primero que todo felicitar a
nuestros oyentes y amigos mexicanos
porque según tengo entendido es el mes
patrio mexicano el mes de septiembre y
es justamente en
[Música]
es para celebrar este mes patrio y para
celebrar también el 75 aniversario de la
relación bilateral entre méxico y canadá
la embajada de canadá
aquí en en ottawa presentó el grupo cam
de canto nuevo a mar y el cuarteto
latinoamericano que es de música
prehispánica muy bonita escuchen el
reportaje y ahí tendrán toda la
información al respecto
adiós ko
ah
[Música]
e